I am Seth Rogen I'm gonna charlize
theron today we're gonna play truth or
dad which means that we will either
answer a question or use a spicy chicken
wing and you can watch it on first we
feast for free for free I think I hope
you should not pay for this
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another episode of truth or dab the
hot ones special where we give our
guests two simple options tell the truth
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
I'm excited to welcome two of the
biggest movie stars in the world not to
mention illustrious hot ones alum Seth
Rogen and Charlize Theron you can catch
them in the hilarious new romantic
comedy the longshot in theaters May 3rd
Charlize Seth welcome to the show thank
you for having us so in the long shot
Seth you play a speech writer yes who
works for char Lisa's character
Charlotte yes
is there a rally cry or call to action
that comes to mind before today's game I
hope to win I hope to defeat Charlie's
breakdown this yeah I got real
aggressive before I'm gonna do what the
[ __ ] we were doing let me break down the
circus act in front of you you have
three scorching hot chicken wings that
have all been doused in various versions
of the last step great I have a series
of deeply personal potentially
uncomfortable questions for each of you
and when I ask you a question you have a
choice answer it honestly or escape the
truth by eating a death wing I'm good
all right Seth we'll start with you
great anyone who's followed you can see
that the drip is out of control these
days it's not uncommon for you to show
up on gqueues best-dressed men of the
week now what has been the biggest most
outrageous celebrity favor you've called
in to get a pair of hypebeast kicks or
garments bonus points if you could tell
us the most you've spent on a pair of
shoes in the last year whoa you're never
gonna recover from this no you'll always
end like the [ __ ] no I think I just
asked Kanye West for shoes when he first
started making them and I got him so it
worked if you're willing to just ask
Kanye West for shoes you don't have to
pay that much for the box but lately so
though I've probably bought some
needlessly expensive shoes I guess a
$1000 I probably spend on I've one pair
of shoes well there's the truth no
chicken wing Forsyth now the tables they
turned towards Charlize alright so your
co-star sathi is known for given great
BTS stories my favorite still the story
about when you actually had to keister
food to pull off a scene in the
interviews where there was a dog that
was supposed to be sniffing your butt
but I'm curious charlise when you look
back at your own film resume what's one
of the most uncomfortable awkward
behind-the-scenes moments for you you
get a DAB no I did mmm I people won't
believe it but it for me ultimately the
most embarrassing thing uncomfortable
thing to do is to do anything that
involves singing it's [ __ ] just it I
just I just did it's really embarrassing
well we won't ask you to sing today one
round down sing or Deb one round down
and Seth you know we dive deep around
here let's do it and this one about 20
years into the Canon yeah I have a good
authority that you recorded an
unreleased hip hop album yes back in the
early 2000s
what are we sort of obviously the
chicken I want to hear that voice your
gender progressively a little bit yeah
[Laughter]
Sharleen you're on hot ones we talked
about your TV guilty pleasures and like
me I know that you're a bachelor
obsessive so here we're gonna test your
knowledge of all things bachelor nation
with three Bachelor trivia questions
oh wait I thought they were gonna walk
out I got it really excited if you get
all three right you're in the clear but
one miss stop it's a one-way ticket to
Scovel City and then Seth I know that
you recently hopped on The Bachelor
bandwagon so if you guys want to work in
cahoots on this one that's cool
no all right I don't know any of their
names
that's okay you might need to hurry
which of the following is not a bachelor
spin-off bachelor pad bachelor in
paradise here for the wrong reasons or
The Bachelor Winter Games bachelor pad
it is here for the wrong it is here for
the wrong show that sounds like a show
we should sell that we should sell they
should sell that down the hatch that
should it goes
[Music]
it's [ __ ] me up this is a hot having
flashbacks inside you want just cashew
milk at any moment oh right this is a
ten yeah this is not bleeding into
adverse this is it goes up to 12 no
foreplay whatsoever right in there oh
yeah whoa oh god oh I know your
competitive spirit my mouth is like in
pain yeah yeah I've been there yeah
all right Seth your extended comedy
family yeah it's an illustrious crew
known for making some of the most
beloved movies of the last 15 years but
it's time to pull back the curtain on
what's going on behind the scenes of the
following actors which one is the most
difficult to work with and why don't
know next you're an Oscar winner with
dozens of iconic roles under your belt
from Mad Max - monster - reindeer games
but we all know that making great art
it's not always a it's not always a walk
in the park of the following directors
which one was the most fun to work with
which one was the least fun to work with
david leitch George Miller Seth
MacFarlane Niki Caro I didn't hear
anything
it's intense right I'm surprised it
[ __ ] her up so bad she's pretty good
with this [ __ ] you're wiping your tongue
off that's not gonna help
seth macfarlane most fun yeah least fun
there's another wing just sitting there
if you don't have [ __ ]
Oh same again we have David Leitch Niki
Caro Seth MacFarlane George Miller use
with Sookie you hear audibly woods again
I know Jacob if you want some of my
cashew nuts Oh [ __ ] intense all right
Seth yup it is now pop quiz time for you
that you have a very cute dog named
Zelda it is widely known that you're
obsessed with the popular Nintendo
franchise so again three Zelda questions
get them all right you're in the clear
but get one wrong legally outlet in
arguing get them what is the maximum
number of rupees link can hold in the
original Legend of Zelda their goods
better actory this one you're numb now
you're good it is multiple choice you
want to take a shot
your tongue is dead it's gonna be fun
yeah sure 101 255 999 999 255 [ __ ] you
it's better I don't feel anything
anymore
we're down my throat I was like it's not
that bad oh okay we are on to the last
wing oh it is the final round and Seth
you have made a lot of friends in
Hollywood plus you're Canadian so I
think it's widely assumed that you're a
very nice dude
but it's time to pull out the knives on
the final round can you look Charlize
Theron in the face and share one
criticism or complaint that you have
after spending months filming this movie
and doing for us together you got this
you can do that I can't think that I
drew Polly can't think of any oh man
like belly button sweating yeah like a
different kind of sweating okay you made
me go on the shop alone you said we
would be there together and that I got
there nope question to you can you look
Seth in the head and if you have
something to get off your chest let him
know but if not down the hatch with
another DEATH way you made me do a
[ __ ] karaoke sin scene all day long
yeah seeing how hard it was for me
seeing how it was traumatizing me I will
never get over it want you to know that
I do know that oh I know truther dad's
stress testing relationship since 2018
make sure to check out the longshot in
theaters May 3rd
Charlize Seth any last words before we
get you into an ice bath
this shit's legit updates hot it's not
like famous person hot it's [ __ ] hot
oh man oh I like jib my lips I know I
put my tongue in here hey what's going
on hot ones fans thank you so much for
watching another episode of truth or dab
and if you're a dab head listen up it's
an important day we are dropping the
newest batch of the Carolina Reaper
addition last dab that's right the last
dab made with smoke and Ed Curry's
Carolina Reapers it drops today and it's
going to be the last of the dabs until
the chili harvest later this summer so
get it while it's hot get it while it's
in stock get some baby
[Applause]